[Music]
on this tuesday night the demand for
details about sweeping new powers
reaction to the federal emergencies act
what it's being used for and why most of
the truckers bank accounts are pretty
well empty right now anyway
the legalities and the politics behind
ottawa's new emergency power 24 hours in
and there are more questions than
answers the changes coming to travel
rules no more pcr tests required what
you need to know before your next
departure
plus mixed messages from moscow russia
says it's pulling back some troops from
ukraine's border an invasion remains
distinctly possible the u.s president
says the threat remains and a golden
performance team canada breaks a record
on the ice at the winter games
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is a lot to get to again tonight
there are changes coming for travelers
including an end to mandatory pcr tests
for fully vaccinated people entering the
country we'll have more on that in just
a moment but we begin with the
emergencies act the federal government
invoked it yesterday the first time
that's happened in canada it gives the
government extraordinary powers and
implies existing laws aren't enough to
end the protests in ottawa the protest
is still going strong the trucks are now
lined up as close as they can get to
parliament hill and ottawa's police
chief the person in charge of enforcing
existing laws has resigned
so what is the impact of all of this
including the government's plan to use
the new powers to choke off funding to
the protesters abigail beeman has our
top story tonight
we are in control by our lord and savior
and he looks after us better than what
our parliament has been doing
parked right in front of parliament the
junkers say they aren't worried about a
frozen bank account most of the truckers
bank accounts are pretty well empty
right now anyway so we we don't put
money into the banks anymore
and because we don't trust the banks
anymore this is about
following the money this is about
stopping the financing the government
wants money laundering and terrorist
financing rules to expand to cover
crowdfunding platforms and payment
service providers which must register
with fintrac banks are asked to report
on those involved in the blockades to
ceases and the rcmp and can freeze
accounts with no court order that is a
fairly serious consequence like impact
these individuals for the rest of their
lives it's not like not being allowed to
travel these people won't be able to get
loans a mortgage possibly a credit card
if this is not handled correctly this is
quite proportionate given that the
damage
that these that these blockades are
doing to people's lives but like all
measures so far it's not deterring
hundreds of people camped out in the
core some don't believe it talking today
about the state of emergency back and
the part there is none okay
done because it's just another scare
tactic i'd love for them to freeze my
bank accounts because they're all in the
minus right now because of this coving
others like jimmy cyr are just plain
frustrated i'm not out here because i
want to topple governments or to to hurt
anybody i'm out here because i've been
hurt so much by this
by these mandates that i can't take it
anymore many ottawa residents say they
can't take all this anymore either chief
peter slowly and the ottawa police
services board reached a mutually
agreeable separation ottawa police chief
peter slowly out tuesday the interim
leadership trying to convince the police
services board the city and beyond that
things will now be under control but i'm
confident that we've reached a turning
point we now have the resources and
partners to bring a safety end to this
occupation ottawa police still won't say
how many of the additional 1800
resources they asked for they now have
nor would the interim police chief share
any details about the plan ottawa police
promise they're working on to end things
but in answering board questions he did
answer the total number of charges laid
for illegal assembly it's zero donna
abigail beeman on parliament hill
tonight thanks now to the emergencies
act there are lots of questions about
what evidence the government has to
invoke it section 3 defines a national
emergency as an urgent and critical
situation of a temporary nature that
seriously threatens the ability of the
government of canada to preserve the
sovereignty security and territorial
integrity of canada and that cannot be
effectively dealt with under any other
law of canada there are checks and
balances in place in the act plus legal
thresholds that must be met those have
yet to be spelled out by the government
david aiken is looking at the legal and
political questions that need some
answers david
well donna we have talked to several
experts over the last two days all of
who say there is considerable doubt as
to whether the government has legally
met the threshold to declare an
emergency
so the government is of canada
essentially having to say that these
protests
threaten the government's ability to
preserve the sovereignty security or
territorial integrity of canada which i
think is
quite a significant thing to be claiming
the emergencies act is not there
to
protect the canadian economy which is
one of the things that the government
has been talking about a lot and despite
press conferences yesterday and again
today with the prime minister and senior
cabinet ministers the government has yet
to provide details or explain why it
believes there is a national emergency
and exactly what it will do about it mr
speaker yesterday the prime minister
invoked the emergencies act 24 hours in
and there are more questions than
answers i want to be very clear mr
speaker the scope of these measures are
time limited
and geographically targeted but does
geographically targeted mean they apply
only to downtown ottawa or to the entire
city is it one border crossing or all
border crossings one province or several
the prime minister did not say details
like that and many more are the kind of
thing that both mps and senators will
want before they vote to confirm the
government's application of the
emergencies act by law both chambers
must begin debating this issue within
the week that debate will be followed by
a vote
and the government must get a majority
in both chambers if it fails in either
chamber well that's it that's the end of
the emergency act and the end of any
special powers the government wants to
exercise donna
okay lots of steps still to come david
aiken in ottawa thanks well the federal
government is easing some testing and
quarantine requirements for fully
vaccinated travelers among the changes
those expensive and lengthy pcr tests
will no longer be required before
arriving in this country mike armstrong
is following this story for us mike take
us through these changes
well donna travel's not opening up
completely but it is getting less
complicated first of all pre-entry
travelers who are coming to canada
you'll still need to show a negative
covid test but as of february 28th it'll
no longer have to be a pcr test a rapid
antigen test administered by a lab
technician will be accepted that's a
less expensive and quicker option for
travelers now upon arrival the rules
will be changing for vaccinated
travelers right now people have to take
a test when they arrive in canada by air
as of the end of the month vaccinated
travelers will only have to be tested if
they're randomly selected also they'll
no longer have to quarantine while
they're waiting for results for
unvaccinated travelers there will be no
change for now they'll still have to be
tested and still have to quarantine the
other big change is for children 11
years old or younger who are not fully
vaccinated if traveling with vaccinated
adults they'll no longer have to
quarantine before going back to school
or daycare again there's no change if
they're traveling with unvaccinated
adults these changes are possible not
only because we have passed the peak of
omicron but because canadians across the
country have listened to the science and
to experts it's about time
oh i think it's a good thing
i travel a couple of times since uh
beginning of the panamic
so
it's always been a little bit harder
since but
yeah i know it's i think it's good yeah
it's better it's going to be better i
think better you know
less roles yeah yeah
yeah everybody for another rules
you know now the other part of this
announcement is how the government
quantifies the danger in traveling it's
no longer going to recommend avoiding
all non-essential travel but at the same
time it's warning canadians to be
careful if you get sick while you're
away it can lead to expensive extensions
of your stay and complications getting
home donna
okay mike armstrong thank you
in alberta the blockade at the coots
border crossing is over the protesters
packed up and left this morning one day
after police made a series of arrests
and seized a cache of weapons and
ammunition heather yorick's west has
been covering this story since it began
heather
donna after 18 days it's over and
protesters say it was the discovery of
weapons here that brought this blockade
to an end
they left town just after breakfast
a long line of tractors trailers and
trucks it's too bad that we have to
leave but it was very everybody that
really their best and to get freedom for
everybody in canada
and it breaks our hearts they'd vowed to
go on blocking the border crossing until
all coveted restrictions were lifted but
protest organizers say this changed
things
a cache of weapons including long guns
handguns and body armor these weapons
were brought by people who had the
intent on causing harm 13 people were
arrested most now face charges of
mischief and weapons possession three
have also been charged with conspiracy
to commit murder our message has been
one of peace peaceful protest
and to keep that message strong we felt
the best decision was to move out
as protesters left coots at a second
protest camp near milk river police took
names and collected information still
under investigation who brought the
weapons to couts and what was their
intent the canadian anti-hate network
says one set of body armor seized by
police displays the local of a group
suspected of promoting hate and violence
we recognized immediately that the
patches were the flag of a network
called diagon basically they're like a
neo-fascist acceleration accelerationist
militia
just before noon tuesday the canadian
border services agency confirmed the
kutz border crossing had reopened to
cross border traffic a relief to many
industries who move tens of millions of
dollars worth of goods through here
every day donna
heather urex west near milk river
alberta tonight thanks heather
another search at two former residential
schools has confirmed what was suspected
signs of what are believed to be 54
unmarked graves a saskatchewan first
nation used ground penetrating radar on
the site northeast of regina eric
sorenson reports on exactly what was
found and a warning some of the details
are disturbing
54 potential grave sites adding to the
hundreds discovered so far in canada
ground penetrating radar made
discoveries at two former residential
schools fort pelly and saint phillips
which operated till the late 1960s ted
cusants was abused and among the first
to speak out more than 30 years ago when
canadians would not listen we all knew
that we would find grave sites grave
sites that he says cannot be ignored
every announcement of residential
schools
residential grave sites re-traumatized
re-traumatizes
us survivors in canada 139 residential
schools have been identified most were
in the west in saskatchewan around 20
residential schools existed the latest
findings near the manitoba border
detected 42 graves at fort peli
residential school which preceded st
phillips school where another 12 graves
have been found and there may be more
chief of the kisakus nation says the
discovery does not bring closure they're
gone to school
and they've never returned
all this has done is it it's opened up
the door for more questions
the memories are agonizing but must be
remembered say indigenous leaders for
what they were these are crime scenes
that's what they are
we have to acknowledge that there has to
be truth before reconciliation
every new discovery and story deserves
to be told the federal minister
acknowledging this country's disgrace
and frankly to witness canada's ongoing
shame in the face of these findings i
believe you
and canada believes you and then there
is the catholic church finally now
working with indigenous nations to
uncover records and seek accountability
and we are
profoundly sorry for the role that
catholics played in the schools
and the abuse that you suffered this
educator doesn't fully trust government
or the church they're not being
forthcoming in bringing information
forward and sharing documents and even
in the government you know it's been a
fight to get release of documents next
month a delegation of indigenous leaders
from canada will travel to the vatican
to meet with pope francis a prelude to
the pope coming to this country at long
last as a gesture of reconciliation
eric sorensen global news toronto
there is a 24-hour crisis line available
for anyone experiencing pain or distress
as a result of the residential school
experience the number is toll free you
can speak in confidence it's
1-800-721-0066
there is a lot on the minds of people in
atlantic canada tonight february 15th is
the 40th anniversary of the ocean ranger
disaster the oil rig sank in the north
atlantic in a terrible storm 84 people
died most of them were from newfoundland
and labrador
and tonight there's a search underway
for the crew of a spanish fishing boat
that sank east of st john's at least 10
people are known to have died rescue
teams are battling rough seas looking
for survivors ross lord is following
developments for us ross
donna the joint rescue coordination
center here in halifax has deployed
ships and aircraft to search for
survivors they include cormorant search
and rescue helicopters a hercules fixed
wing airplane and a coast guard ship
a u.s coast guard plane has also been
sent out three survivors from the 24-man
crew were found by another spanish
fishing boat in a life raft the rescue
center says searchers have found some
items including life jackets fishing
gear and two empty life rafts obstacles
to the search include distance from
shore and stormy conditions the weather
was uh pretty intense in the area winds
were southwest 40. seas were five meters
plus and of course it was night which
hampered searching
today the weather is moderated searchers
have better visibility but waves are
still more than three meters high
spanish officials say the crew members
include spanish nationals and crew
members from ghana and peru
the rescue center says its policy is to
keep searching until there's no
possibility of survivors
the center says the decision will be
made tomorrow morning on scaling back
the search donna
all right ross thank you
mixed signals along the russia-ukraine
border coming up the american
president's warning after the kremlin
claims it's pulling back some of its
troops
the american president joe biden says he
thinks a russian invasion of ukraine is
still a distinct possibility despite
claims by russia it is pulling back some
of its troops
and make no mistake
the united states will defend every inch
of nato territory
with the full force of american power
an attack against one nato country's
attack against all of us
biden said today the u.s is not seeking
direct confrontation with russia but as
jackson proskow reports he says nato is
prepared and russia will pay a steep
price if it invades
in an urgent push for diplomacy the
american president issued a stark
warning and a plea for peace to the
citizens of russia
you are not our enemy
and i do not believe you want a bloody
destructive war against ukraine
it came on a day of more mixed messages
from russia
the kremlin said it planned to pull back
some troops from border areas russia's
parliament requested vladimir putin
recognize russian-backed separatist
regions in ukraine
as independent states
and after a meeting with the german
chancellor putin made unsupported claims
of genocide in ukraine's donbass region
do we want war of course not he said so
far
we have not seen any sign of
de-escalation on the ground
true or not analysts see hopeful signs
in russia's claims of a modest troop
pullback i take it as a step back and i
take it as a hopeful sign again very
cautiously that he's prepared to step
away and negotiate some of the
issues
ukraine now surrounded on three sides by
150 000 russian troops sees less reason
for optimism an apparent cyber attack
hit several banks and government
websites tuesday while back in
washington the tone of the american
president suggested serious concern that
putin may not be talked down let there
be no doubt
if russia commits this breach by
invading ukraine
responsible nations around the world
will not hesitate to respond
tonight ukraine has made an emergency
request to nato for supplies to prepare
for what it calls large-scale crises
affecting its civilian population among
the items they're seeking demining
equipment explosives detection equipment
and medical supplies all ominous signs
of what may be to come
donna
jackson proskow in washington
prince andrew settles the lawsuit
against him ahead what he admitted to
and what it means
[Music]
prince andrew has reached an
out-of-court settlement with the woman
who accused him of sexually assaulting
her when she was 17. it means he will
avoid going to trial in new york but it
doesn't mean he's admitted any guilt our
redmond shannon is in london tonight
redmond what is being made public about
this settlement
donna we don't know how much the
settlement was for but this outcome was
always likelier than seeing the prince
on trial tuesday's filing from lawyers
representing virginia dufrey and prince
andrew includes no admission of guilt on
the duke's behalf he previously denied
ever knowing her but it does say he
accepts that she has suffered both as an
established victim of abuse and as a
result of the unfair public attacks
it also says he will make a substantial
donation to ms dufrey's charity in
support of victims rights and that he
regrets his association with convicted
sex offender jeffrey epstein we may now
never know the full extent of their
friendship andrew had been scheduled to
give a sworn statement to duprey's
lawyers next month now he avoids that
and a civil trial a court case in new
york would have been unthinkable it
would have been an international cause
celeb there would have been
so much humiliation
even though these legal troubles are
behind andrew his reputation is damaged
already stripped of his military titles
and royal patronages his days as an act
of royal appear to be over
donna
redmond shannon in london tonight thank
you
skating to success next team canada's
golden nail biter at the winter olympics
[Music]
team canada is celebrating another gold
medal the second at these winter games
the women's speed skating trio won the
team pursuit event and set a new olympic
record doing it it was a nail biter
japan crashed into the wall on the final
turn giving canada the
gold and quebec's max perot landed back
on the podium for a second time in
beijing he won bronze in big air
snowboarding perrault hopes this will
put an end to criticism of his gold
medal win in the slope style event last
week his victory there was called into
question after judges didn't dock him
points for missing a board grab in his
first run the 27 year old has been
putting on quite a show at these games
three years after being declared
cancer-free
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen tonight's your
canada is peli crossing in yukon there
are beautiful spots all over this
country please email us yours to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching and hope to see you
here again tomorrow take care of
yourselves bye-bye
[Music]